cargo traffic in the suez canal is  finally flowing this afternoon after  this  skyscraper-sized ship that blocked the  suez canal  was finally freed this morning the ship  known as the ever given  was finally moved after hours of pushing  and pulling and prodding  for days dredgers sucked up nearly a  million cubic feet of sand and mud  but mother nature also lent a hand to  get that ship unstuck  a full moon high tide raised the canal's  water level  the blockage though created a traffic  jam of nearly 400 ships  the canal can take about 50 or 60 ships  a day so there is going to be  some delay as they free up this backlog  the suez canal carries about 10 percent  of the world's trade including 7 percent  of its oil